There is no way on earth to prevent the
rise of the intelligent machines about
this case at Facebook and this idea
that perhaps these robots where somehow
developing an independent language,
much smarter than a person,
what does that,
what job do we have?
Yeah,
so enough about the evil Ai.
Let's talk about the good stuff,
and then no one talks about
the good stuff and they should,
because in the worst case,
it creates a Dystopia, right?
It, it kills us. All, right?
That's in the worst case,
but in the best case,
it solves literally every single problem
that we could ever imagine if global
warming disease, famine, poverty,
any huge intractable problem
and he multivariant problem,
it could solve.